angel was Saphira is harvesting spinach
and Mangold cheese's students of gay as
a high school in the Ugandan capital
Kampala linked to the school was an area
of land just a hundred square meters in
size where the students can grow
vegetables angel uses old plastic
containers for plant pots as a way of
recycling waste so most of these are non
biodegradable they do not decompose so
instead of either banning them and
producing small country polygamists fear
or maybe burying them in the ground that
is going to destroy - all organisms we
can recycle them and use them to grow
crops which are going to leave or change
angel and her classmates mostly grow
cabbage spinach and spring onions the
boarding school on the outskirts of
Kampala is a pioneer in urban farming
and encourages its students to take
their skills home with them gardening
lessons take place once a week the
veggies are consumed at school or sold
to members of the public on visiting
days the head teacher says the project
is a huge success maybe 90% of the girls
I have raised in the urban area and this
is critical for us because they have to
be active somebody can earn money in
place is a small place can earn money
regardless of how small a place can be
the initiative is paying off angel has
even inspired her parents to grow
vegetables at home they retired so they
have enough time to take care of the
plants because these days if I'm
preparing my breakfast I pick a few a
few leaves and then I cut and put in my
food yeah it saved a lot because you
find that every day I spend around two
thousand three thousand pages but if you
have them around home safely a lot
urban farming is still in its infancy in
Uganda the students hope to get
financial support from the government as
the initiative is rolled out to other
schools the Minister of Education is
already full of praise for the project
feeding the children will not become a
problem saving the environment will be
very important I mean will be very we
will be done because we have seen the
way they are using the polythene and
they all do things and so on so we shall
not be polluting the environment they
will be utilizing those very things to
use as guidance on the verandas
whatever they don't consume the students
sell on visiting days one large cabbage
earns the school around one u.s. dollar
but monies pull together and used to
help pay for food at boarding school on
a larger scale urban farming has the
potential sack of food insecurity and
unemployment but for the students
growing their own crops as first and
foremost a lot of fun